another revlog is on the campaign Trail
in Guatemala but just a few days ago it
looked like he'd be permanently thrown
off it the Attorney General's office had
tried to suspend him from Guatemala's
presidential runoff accusing his party
samiya of registering thousands of
members illegally in order to qualify as
a party
a revolo denies that and says the charge
was politically motivated it was quashed
temporarily by the Constitutional court
but he told us he expects more legal
challenges ahead and we know that they
are going to be they probably will try
to use whatever measures they have at
hand in order to try to stop us well
first of all I think that the day he
refers to is not just the Attorney
General's office but an entrenched
oligarchy in Guatemala that he says
fears for me is push for reform and they
basically corrupt system of political
parties and people that have been
milking the cow of the state and that
now they're about to lose everything
three other candidates were thrown out
the race before even the first round of
voting among them the front runner all
were considered capable of changing the
system we are very aware that this is no
longer about samija this is about the
people about everybody this is about the
nation and it has been really very
rarely in the last years that we have
seen such world-to-wall alignment of
people saying no we're fed up we have to
contain this attack to the institutions
and we need to go ahead after the
disqualification of the other candidates
voters spoiled or left empty one of four
ballots in the first round others voted
for a revel formerly polling at less
than three percent that was a protest
against the system and our 12 percent is
again a protest against the system if
you do become president what's the most
important thing for you to do Dad we
need to show the people that once you
take out corruption from the formula you
can get institutions to operate again
and to begin
to deliver
everything that we need in this society
that has been abandoned by A system that
has not has not been about the needs of
the people but the needs of that corrupt
Clique
strong clean institutions a revolo says
it's the base to tackle Guatemala's
Myriad problems unemployment rampant
Street crime the second worst infant
mortality rate in the Americas
but the investigation against his party
is still open despite the injunction the
Attorney General's office is not backing
down
on the August the 20th runoff but if
they'll make it there at all
if they don't there'll be even more
questions than before about Guatemala's
teacher in democracy John Holman Al
Jazeera Santa Maria de Jesus Guatemala